climat alors dérèglement climatique ou
pas les experts sont partagés nous
retrouvons en duplex de genève michel
jarraud secrétaire général adjoint de
l'organisation météorologique mondiale
michel jarraud bonsoir le météorologue
convient l'entente dit qu'il n'y a pas
plus de phénomènes climatiques qu'avant
est ce que vous êtes vous même de cet
avis écoutez je crois que il y a
toujours eu comme l'a dit le
météorologiste des phénomènes extrêmes
dans tous les coins de la planète
un des phénomènes nouveaux c'est qu'il
ya une globalisation de l'information et
par exemple les inondations d'où vous
venez parler pour la chine
les chutes de neige en amérique latine
la fonte de la banquise en antarctique
n'aurais pas fait les titres des
journaux il ya 50 ans donc je crois
qu'une prise de conscience maintenant
plus globale de ces phénomènes extrêmes
de ces catastrophes
l'autre aspect c'est que toutes ces
catastrophes ont un impact humain plus
important qu autrefois est également un
impact économique plus important
pourquoi en grande partie à cause de la
croissance démographique qui font que
beaucoup plus de gens habitent dans des
zones à risque
alors la question il ya monsieur jarraud
excusez moi est-ce que c'est lié vous
dites on n'en parle plus c'est vrai ça
fait la une des médias il ya les
populations qui habitent dans ces zones
mais est ce que ces phénomènes sont liés
entre eux
ça c'est une question très très
difficile il ya certains phénomènes
comme le phénomène el niño dont je pense
beaucoup de gens ont entendu parler qui
entraîne des conséquences
je dirais planétaire c'est à dire que ça
va se traduire par une sécheresse dans
le nord-est du brésil des inondations
dans d'autres parties de l'amérique
latine des conséquences en indonésie en
asie du sud est donc d'un phénomène
comme el niño a un impact quasi quasi
globales et dans une paire dentinho
effectivement certain nombre de
phénomènes extrêmes sont reliés entre
eux mais je crois qu'il faut être
prudent également et ne pas dire el niño
est responsable de tous les maux qui
peuvent se produire ici ou là sur la
planète mais il ya aussi la tenue ce
week il ya aussi le réchauffement de la
planète dont on parle régulièrement
alors est ce qu'il faut le prendre en
considération est ce que c'est crédible
à tout à fait tout à fait et le
réchauffement de la planète
et un est un fait il y a de plus en plus
de gaz à effet de serre qui sont
relâchés par les activités humaines
d'atmosphère du co2 du méthane d'autres
gaz etc gaz entraîne un réchauffement de
la planète et on prévoit qu'au cours des
des cent prochaines années
ce réchauffement va se situer dans une
fourchette de 1 degré et demi à 6 degrés
globalement alors concrètement qu'est ce
qui se passe que ce qui se passe si on a
six degrés de réchauffement et tombe
dans un demi siècle ou dans un siècle
alors 6 degrés il faut savoir que c'est
l'écart qui sépare une période glaciaire
d'une période interglaciaire et l'autre
l'autre considération c'est que ce
réchauffement ne sera pas uniforme
il y aura des zones où réchauffement
sera beaucoup plus important et d'autres
où il sera moins important et une des
conséquences prévues de ce changement
climatique c'est qu'effectivement un
certain nombre de phénomènes extrêmes
peuvent se trouver à graver en
particulier les phénomènes de type
hydrologie plus d'inondations dans
certaines régions des sécheresse accrue
dans d'autres en europe
concrètement une étude de l'union
européenne il ya quelques années a
montré qu'il y aurait sans doute plus
d'innovation dans la partie nord et
ouest de l'europe et que les sécheresses
par contre s'aggraverait dans la partie
sud de l'europe
très bien merci merci beaucoup monsieur
gérard d'avoir accepté l'invitation du
soir 3